e-body renew by madame
masseur specializes in non-physical
workouts and
luxury rocky caught up with the team to
see their location at the sterling club
when you enter the beautiful and
prestigious sterling club
you're greeted by friendly service and
luxury
whether you're enjoying the salon the
spa
the gym or e-body renew
the treatment is a combination of
a machine and a diet
this is excellent in the time of covert
because we all
feeling depressed and down what the
treatment does it helps the endorphins
in the brain
and make you feel better and make you
relax you come to the salon twice a week
we take care of you we pamper you
we help you with your eating plan we
motivate you
because motivation is what we all need
at the moment
this is beautiful amy she needed to just
tone
and firm and use a bit of cellulite and
get a bit of strength
my experience has been fantastic i love
coming here for my treatments and i
usually have a couple problem areas like
cellulite
my arms and my stomach so i come in and
do these treatments and i feel great not
only do i get a workout
and get my muscles tone but i'm getting
ready for my photo shoots for my
pageants
and afterwards the stamina that i have
after the treatments are incredible
she's getting strained from the
treatment she's getting sculpted from
the treatment
because remember it's not like a laser
that is just going to break down your
fatty tissue it's going to stream from
your muscle
and women aren't the only ones who
deserve this kind of
special treatment the treatment is
really incredible
it is open to everybody men and women
overweight patients and non-overweight
patients
and children can go on the treatments
but what i
really specify and work on is men that
wants to lose that little extra
executive gut you know you're in the gym
all day you work out you do everything
you can do but you can't get rid of it
my machines goes down and break down the
fatty tissue and do muscle react
so get rid of your gut ben
is a wonderful client of mine
international business executive from
australia so you hear all these accents
here
we helped him to get rid of that little
gut that he had
been amazing to go through those
treatments uh the last couple of months
and i think we're up to about 10
treatments now and i think i've lost
about
four inches off off the stomach in that
time and uh
about six pounds as well so you can go
to the gym all day you can go do cardio
all day
but unless you really know how to target
those muscles
and break down that fat that's going to
stay there anybody renew doesn't just
give you
give you weight loss or shape your body
eat body when you
create blood circulation throughout your
body and will detox your body
i think it's done a lot for my
metabolism because i never really
noticed
anything changing hormonally or anything
because of
the body for instance my lungs were bad
and they're fixed now because it gets
all the ox
it's just so good for everything
check out ebody renew at the starting
club for more information you can call
that number seven zero two four four
four zero two two nine
or go to their website at ebodyrenew.com
they have a really good special right
now you can get your first 179 dollar
value treatment for just
69 jc